that's going as you can see I've got
almond that's some very prepared I've
got a PowerPoint with no pictures in the
woods that's it that's this my
powerpoint it says one page my name
screen Rice's lecture series British
Academy of Film and Television Arts and
supported by the JJ Charitable Trusts
and at BAFTA guru that's some of my text
I put in there it's to prove I did write
something I've eaten a good two minutes
in the 86 to go okay I did this the word
lecture that's still mean you know I
mean this is a loose term really isn't
it lecture I'm here to talk to you guys
about screenwriting I don't know much
about screenwriting but I thought that
what would be nice for us and for me
let's just have a conversation with you
guys should get me off the hook in a big
way having no notes and nothing prepared
just kind of how I've operated in there
you should not take any photos I do not
want a record of this
should be deleted from everyone's
memories at 4:00 p.m. so yeah thanks for
having me Beth them judging Charitable
Trusts it's lovely to be here
I saw hid last night I was at a bar and
I smashed my head into a bookcase and so
of those aching headache right here
right just here so if anyone here I've
had two paracetamol but if anyone has
any more just throw them on the water so
it's going great
now screenwriting what do we know about
screenwriting hmm
where do we start mmm at the beginning
title page the thing is you need a good
title page it's where all scripts are
the scripts in my experience live and
die on the title page and a good title
you know it's what are your favorite
titles movies just for them out there
boy my my film simple it's just three
little word
and it says it all doesn't it okay page
one after the title page he needs to
page one and it's where all good scripts
net and unit start with either interior
or exterior so you also need to be good
at typing now you either fast time for a
slow typer
I'm the fast typer but slower ideas so
most of my scripts have taken this the
truth probably about seven years between
writing and getting made if I first
started still see going into actually
the real talk now I was and filmmaking
was never really my dream wasn't my it
was like a wasn't my type top shelf
dreams
lower level bottom shelf dream I had
other dreams that I didn't achieve
disappointed very disappointed in that
but bittersweet because also now rich
so sometimes you just go take one for
the team and just you know you just got
to swallow that pill them and and get a
career in film so yeah you just got to
do it I started off as a as an
illustrator and painter and my my
background was visual arts it's hot in
here
and it's oh yeah so that was my dad as a
painter he was painting and a farmer my
mother was a schoolteacher and for
punishment she would make me analyze
poems and William Blake pushes a you've
been bad now I want you to write an
essay on this William Blake poem [ __ ]
yeah
so I used to have to do that so I was
really fought I wasn't ever forced or
encouraged to do things outside of the
arts because both my parents were into
the arts and they wanted me to do that
so so was I was encouraged to pursue
that and I'm very thankful for that so
yeah so most of my life was spent doing
music and drama and and art and
eventually my late twenties I decided to
to write that short film which is
actually better than that when you can
hear the dialogue that was something
that I I was I was already writing a lot
of comedy and doing stand-up and a lot
of sketches and plays and stuff with my
friends because no one would hire us to
do like the beaut plays and [ __ ] so like
we would be forced to make our own stuff
up and make our own props and and and be
more inventive with how we try to tell
our stories and at the time in New
Zealand there wasn't a lot of comedy
going on well a lot of the comedy was
very um it was just it was pretty boring
and it was I think a friend of mine went
to pitch a TV show at TVNZ and they said
can you just make it more like friends
and which is basically what we did we
would just say what was America making
and they would
copy that and so that was like the
extent of what we're doing in comedy on
TV and so yeah so we just basically
tried to to swim against that tide and
we just did these strange sketches and
weird things it's just Jemaine and Bret
and I and a few other people and and so
we kind of created our own style of
comedy I guess or the own style of of
storytelling own style of writing and
then eventually people ended up liking
it and then in my late 20s I started
writing films because I've not tried it
before and I wrote that I actually wrote
that as a play sort of like for myself
and maybe a couple of friends to play
these kids and like a one-act play and I
sent that script to a friend of mine who
was a producer a film producer and she
suggested that we turn it into a short
film and then we did that and and then
that got nominated for an Oscar and then
lost and so yeah so there's another
failure that my life just just lots of
disappointments really one after the
other and so that but then what the good
thing was I got encouraged to keep
writing more and to keep trying to
experiment and and follow this path and
and that's did a few more short films
and some were made a lot weren't and
then eventually I got to go to the
Sundance labs with my first feature
script which was for Eagle versus shark
and that sort of changed everything for
me when I realized that that
screenwriting could be their writing
films or telling stories could be so
much bigger than than what I originally
had thought it could be which you know
New Zealand now assume it at the time
was basically there's Samuel coin the
phrase the sermo of the unnies which is
basically depressing is raining all the
time and someone definitely dies and
there's definitely a ghost
so and and yeah so it's a I came back so
we all kind of came through at a time
when when I think the the film industry
in New Zealand needed a break from that
or just needed to go in a new direction
and so I was very lucky to kind of sort
of just catch that little wave a little
very little wave and and then yet made
my first my first feature and he kept
getting encouraged to make more and more
and more and so I really fell in love
with film sort of like an arranged
marriage really just fell in love with
it because I was encouraged to and now
I'm definitely in love and and yeah but
so but but I was never someone who was
like a make your old running around with
the camera you know dreaming of making
films like you know bigger than those
guys so it was but I'm actually glad
that I spent you know 28 years getting
experiences another doing other areas
and doing many other jobs and doing
shitty jobs and doing you know like
diving for seaweed as a job and
definitely hospitality and yeah there's
all sorts of things just to get by
but I think there's a lot of experiences
and that that that I've always drawn on
which has helped me a lot in my writing
so whenever people say oh it's a shitty
job but just one like make my first
feature well this home 21 if you student
oak appear some great but for me I think
my fifth I'd made a feature at 21 it
would have been terrible and I wouldn't
be here so I'm really thankful to head
that time that leader of about 28 years
to get experiences which I still draw on
today the end button
so that's that's that but questions is
it your turn to come up now and see how
a chat with me okay well that's the sort
of that's the introduction it's we're
going great and we are going to get into
a debate I do very many have a
conversation though I think the best way
either learning or finding out the other
Alice's just talking to them instead of
just watching films so so we're going to
do that eventually but first you and I
can have a conversation I'm gonna move
over to this area
[Applause]
so apparently the short film is ready to
watch the well we'll play that right at
the end let's begin with automatics and
looking going on from two cars one night
a film that seems deeply personal and
about childhood and perhaps a childhood
that is reflective of your own
experience is that fair to say yeah for
sure
so that film set and outside a pub that
I used to sit outside when I was a kid
in cars and and I've never really seen
anything like although our short films
in New Zealand up until then were there
was a punch line so it was always like
oh it's the same guy but it's a
different day and it's like oh he's like
Groundhog Day but it's like you know so
eight minutes of time what's going on oh
I get it
I get he's a time traveler so um so but
for me I wanted to be something that
felt like part of a bigger thing and
there's more of a snapshot and just
something that felt a little more poetic
and didn't have a punch line at all
there's no plan in there just melancholy
as well yeah which yeah but there also I
think that that set the tone for a lot
of the things I've I've made which is a
mixture of of melancholy and comedy and
and it's I don't think you can ever say
my films are straight-up comedies
because my forms comedies with lots of
slow bits weird there's no laughs or
their dramas are too funny yeah comedies
tragic comedies um but we'll skip her
head if we can to boy just because I
think they're the theme of childhood
from two cars one night boy and then
hunt for the older people is something
that you explore so oh you write
children really well um I don't like
you're right not much yes you there
nuanced and the fallible and there the
way that kids are where has kind of that
exploration of childhood come from why
is that a constant thread I think is
when I was a kid I've spent a lot of
time by myself or with you know my
friends and not a lot of time with
grownups or I'd say that the grown-ups
around us were very unreliable and so
they and so I learned early on that you
can't really trust them you can't trust
grownups really you know I think I'm
trustworthy but but but back then when I
was growing up you really just sort of
had to make do with what you had and and
make your own fun and make your own
dinner and like basically survive and in
keep yourself alive and so we all my
family and I and all the kids I grew up
with we all Greta boyars sit in the
house that I grew up in and a lot of my
family is in the film and two cars is
kind of sort of yeah it's sort of like a
precursor to that film in there you know
that's very specific to how I grew up
and and that and I I never liked him
like lamented that or felt like oh you
know I need some sort of pity or that
these films were an exorcism of my
trauma but I think that there's a lot of
funny parts are there and there so
that's why so boy essentially is comedy
about child neglect and and but then
there's something that like you guys get
it here in America they were very
uncomfortable with that film because
they just did not like the idea that
that parents could be that useless and
and so yeah but I I New Zealand we find
that kind of stuff really funny and I'm
sure you guys do as well
yeah yeah who finds child abuse funny so
sorry yeah but but yeah so we're -
growing up you know we we basically
controlled our own worlds and I think
that's why I've always been drawn to
that joined to the idea of like seeing
this world that shitty grown-ups are
creating through the lens of someone
who's more innocent and who is actually
probably more wise and has a little bit
more perspective like a bit of
perspective on things
then we do because and then in say with
acting like I think that you know
Charlie actors especially if the
untrained infinitely better than Dan
Crona factors because they they don't
press this [ __ ] and they don't go oh my
backstory was I was abused my Carrie was
abused this morning they just want to
say the lines and then eat the free food
and so it's very like pure so they're
like yeah they're not clouded with all
this sort of crap that we carry along
when I was trying to act just like was
my motivation in the same which are I
things achieve it really but yeah and
you write that purity really well
especially in boy in the sense that his
imagined world has imagined world of
where his father is and who he's been is
something kind of that's another layer
that's added I have within your writing
of it in terms of the writing of
something I bought because there are
kind of his a principals perspective but
we do go to other perspectives how do
you what's your person temper sitting
down and doing it is it visual is it
just a desk on your own well a lot of it
comes from like especially those films
comes from just trying to trying to
capture things I remember doing when I
was a kid and and so it's a pair of boy
is this kid he he's fantasize as dead as
dead as a Michael Jackson and and that
he's like off you know doing all these
amazing things over overseas and and
that's exactly how we used to talk it
was like you know when our parents went
around or idea our dads went around we'd
say like I'm
saying that my daddy was it like this
deep sea like exploration diver because
I could on some like rig in the Indian
Ocean that started so we all right and
we all knew we were lying you know we
were like lying and beard in Sun City
I'm saying these ridiculous making up
these ridiculous tales about appearance
but there was something kind of cool
that we were trying to teach other with
these imaginative like excuses of why
our parents went around and so and so I
really love that idea just yeah we
thought that Bob Marley was for my tribe
down the road but we that I read I
really did think that and so yes it's
all tapping into that kind of thing you
know where the imagination actually is
stronger in their reality and actually
eclipsed reality and in a lot of ways
because boy is so personal perhaps based
on people that you know and part of your
childhood you ever feel a responsibility
in terms of what people's perception may
be of those communities no no and and
I've had people who and usually white
people you know you really didn't paint
you at the Maori community in a good
light in their movie and there as and
then some people who say it like in you
know some of the reviews like one review
we got which was saying that it was the
exact same the same thing and then
saying that the film wasn't culturally
specific enough and that basically that
what they're saying is that there were
enough people riding whales and [ __ ] and
film so you know there's like there
weren't enough ghosts and people like
talking to trees and spirits and [ __ ]
and so but yeah I don't feel I feel the
response related to my community into
Maori community just in terms of wanting
to inspire people to get to do other
jobs sort of you what I'm doing and I
think I've succeeded in that in that
respect because there are now a lot of a
lot of youth who want to get into
filmmaking
storytelling which is yeah we were an
oral culture so you know but most of our
I mean all of our history has been
passed down through your story and
through through song and through dance
and through just telling stories which
is where you get where myth comes from
and where you know the retelling of a
simple story just gets more and more
outlandish in like you know which is
where Maui all the exploits of Maui
comes from which is you know he was
probably a dude who you know cut down a
tree you know with like a tiny little
rock once and then that story does women
to like fishing up islands and slowing
the Sun in life of a thousand years so
but I think that's really great because
there's no real I mean what is the truth
in history you know I mean every week
still kind of really rely on books
because it's still one person's telling
of history so you know what's the
difference between a book and stories
that are passed down from generation to
generation just through songs or you
know through available available talent
so yes a my responsibility really is I I
see is to encourage young people in our
community to to to embrace storytelling
again
which is I think one of our strengths
but something that we've just been lost
over the years because we've been
encouraged to to do other things and you
know in my town when I was growing up
there only two jobs really there's like
either driving or working in the
forestry forestry or driving a track
that took the wood out of the forestry
so that was it or you know or or maybe
working on the water fishing or ground
up and so that was like so there was no
which one pays the bit yeah
so yeah so that so those were the
options and if you were to say as a kid
I mean no one would only be hit by only
FileMaker he would NIV it I've heard
that but now here all the time and not
just cuz of me that was it a lot of
other just like my friends and peers
Maori filmmakers who are doing similar
things to me
- microphone right here so part of the
my gift to you
well sticking with childhood and hunt
for the world people broke box office
records in New Zealand yes made 50,000
[Laughter]
and you know pound isn't worth it much
anymore it's not be about your first
adaptation and for the world yeah yeah
yeah and what was if I'm being hurt
having your own voice and being so
distinctive in your voice and map again
being different in every project you've
done but then adapting someone else's
work um had to come about I was
approached to adapt this book by a
radical Barry Crump who is very famous
in New Zealand and and the book is not
really that much like the film it's a
for the film the books not funny and I
had had a lot of a lot more characters
and tried to make it sort of my own
thing but I wrote the first draft from
2005 and it was back then when I thought
I was like this is right after to pass
one night it was before I'd made
anything I mean before I mean after the
show yeah but fraud I'd shot my first
feature and I've wrote there and um and
yeah I you know I was like very much
into being a very kind of you know I
wanted to I was wanting to make like
Korean cinema in like sort of like von
trier seven back that dark and
depressing New Zealand films and so in
that version of the script there were
basically no jokes
Sam Neal's character dies at the end
gets shot to death by the cops the kid
goes back into foster care in this area
no it doesn't go back into foster you
get sows living on the street
Amanda
living in a pack a twelve-year-old
wronged me so so then I put that aside
and I wouldn't made a few other films
and they've kind of got a taste for what
what my style is all you know what the
kind of stories I want to tell and then
yeah and of the years realized it's okay
to put ridiculous [ __ ] in movies and
it's like the world needs stupid stuff
you know and it was the only news hat
and stuff but you need jokes like that
world needs to laugh and so and also I
just don't I just couldn't really see
myself making super depressing like
horrible can movies so if I wanted like
any of my films to go to care for the
world of people to go to can't everyone
would have been dead and prostitutes so
did you think that um you know drama is
something that is revered by festivals
or you know sometimes wild why but
comedy is I know it's so dumb it's gonna
be so much harder to do especially when
it's when it's something tragic yeah in
a drama like if it's snowing laughs
that's good yeah you know the comedy of
non laughs didn't that you're dead so
like that's so been a drama it's like
you can't you it's I've consider it to
be a little easier because it's just say
the words and don't make me laugh that's
your job as an actor in a drama just
don't make anyone crack up so then in
the comedy it's infinitely harder to to
just taught us to shape it and to keep
the laughter going and then to know how
do they work balance the flow of it and
and you know and then you know either to
me like what we do in the shadows we did
cuts where it was like we had to
concentrate on the story and at the
expense of a lot of the jokes and then
we did another cut was all jokes and not
much story and neither of them worked
the one that was full of jokes no one
cared about the characters and they were
like on the fact they were like that's
finally it's for always funny but I
don't care anyone I'm just on my phone
and I look what they're looking and in
the drama land I mean that the story
vision was just boring
how'd you test those things they do it's
just my friends right yeah you have a
trusted group of people it yeah yeah
yeah I mean they're usually just just
people that you've met anywhere I just
well you start he's like running out of
here so like one one of the last hit
screens we did of what we do in the
shadows was at my house with one person
and there was the lap I say our last
friend and he's in the movie and so it's
like me Jermaine and him and my lounge
room in just Jemaine and I just looking
at him he's not laughing it's all you do
ran out of for it yeah but we always
tests I'm always testing in my films and
just sometimes you don't even need to
ask them questions afterwards sometimes
it's just being in a room with some
other people and what I do is I watch my
films in a suit I'd make a note of the
time when I feel embarrassed and then
that's my notes hmm at one hour I felt
pretty shitty like I really wanted to
disappear into a corner and then open
know to go and have a look at that
section well we did in the shadows so
you co-wrote that with Jemaine Hammond
yeah what the difference is in
co-writing how does it work how do you
write with him
it's just slower well mood of people
took 10 years this one no this we came
up with the idea in 2005 and you shorter
than mm yeah of the good year I'm gonna
get I've started so I wanna get you know
and you start you know these things yeah
you got it you're just gonna do it
I just I wouldn't be able sitting here
the rest of the afternoon and knowing
that they weren't all taken out so a
slow process
I'm rushing that's fine need an applause
except that this little triumph for me
today in the coffee cup so yeah so Jim
and I came out of the idea in 2005 and
we are I think we write together well
but we it's excruciating ly slower so we
made six seven years wearing that and I
don't even know wife guru didn't even
show it to the cast we didn't show the
script to anyone other than the HIDs and
we could we improvised the whole face of
the whole film we knew you'd like going
into a scene what we wanted to do and so
we'd get the cast in then would say okay
so in this scene so Ike one example that
you came in one day and we said Jesus
fly down here in the grass and there was
I started pouring blood all over him
dead and we didn't tell anyone really
what was happening to their characters
just because we wanted to feel really
feel like a documentary so people's I
would say here's the goal from you know
from the beginning of the scene to the
end of the scene yeah you have to get
this achieved you have to you know
here's your mission is to get this
convinces person to do this or you know
made of this person awesome and so which
was good so every take was very
different and at the end of the filming
we had about 150 hours of footage that
we had to get down to about 90 minutes
so took 14 months to edit so we were
going through everything and every take
was completely different and so we built
we built the interior of the house and
we pre lit everything so that the camp
we could go into any room we wanted and
create three cameras running all the
time sometimes it's okay we'll just
stick with this character and halfway
through the scene and the
most of the things about ten-minute
takes 15 minute eggs and sodium halfway
through a scene maybe carry a [ __ ]
sound out of here and walk and then the
character would think that camera would
follow them into their bedroom and just
sit with him for a bit as they were
sitting there fuming about something and
then that come back and and so yes
everything was very different and there
was a very different style of start
different style of writing as well where
we we would remain I were in New York
for about six months and we would meet
up every day at about 2 p.m. at this
cafe and have some avocado on toast and
then write like two sentences and three
hours in there and I would just sit
there silent it's how we write sitting
silence and then Jamaica mmm what if
students are the wolf okay I'm good
dinner see that and then we're just like
it was a order that seen each other an
email and be like one sentence I was
thinking maybe the movies a year they go
flying with Nick okay so it's really
long though I don't recommend that in
terms of getting it funded then with the
if you don't have a and a physical
completed script when you're shooting we
had that we had a good script the script
was actually pretty good but we didn't
we just didn't show it so this movie
that we had that we shot and we were
basically shot the script that we would
turner everyone else would have sides
and they'd have a version that they just
wouldn't show the actors the actors just
weren't allowed to see stuff and it was
funded by the New Zealand film they give
us a little bit of money and but it was
also probably a private funding private
there which means you I can't tell you
where it came from
yeah if they want to remain principle
yeah but those were very photo was a
great way of shooting and and you know
this like I think a lot of people don't
consider improvising to be part of the
writing process but over it I do
like I think you if you're coming up
with stuff and it's adding to the
character or it's changing the story in
some way do you think that this that's
writing even though the actors don't get
credit for and that's now so that's now
developed into a TV the TV Shane's been
off yet - TV spin-offs yeah yeah one
that follows the two cops and that sort
of like a boring x-files sit in New
Zealand with the two cops investigating
paranormal events around Wellington
season two I mean how long can you
stretch that yeah and then the other one
there's a spin-off of shadows which is
set in America with new vampires but
it's in the same like universe where our
characters would be in New Zealand at
the same time this is different
documentary crew following these guys
around
and now characters have may or may not
come in - you know - some of these
episodes as well that yeah yeah Matt met
Barry's on that mustachio Demetria is
there more pressure on that then in
terms of kind of you know script or is
it still is it still you and Jemaine or
are you doing right I didn't do any
writing on that because I was doing some
other stuff but but yeah it's pretty
similar jemaine's been doing most of the
writing with another with a writing team
and I'm just gonna go and direct some of
them I'm gonna open it up to the
audience right now okay we've got hands
already okay um we have microphone in
the fourth row yeah
just a couple of questions one first
like thank you but it's impossible not a
question um
it's impossible to find any of your
scripts online and I search for like all
of them and it's nearly impossible to
download them the closest thing that I
came to was an option of one of your
scripts in New Zealand an actual printed
copy one copy of all the scripts
pet paper is the New Zealand government
hesitate okay all right yeah no would
there ever be available or is there I'm
sure that yeah squad email don't kind of
like yeah I want to feel like people
they should be available hundred other
people because one thing that was really
beautiful he was the bear lace hardly in
the film but like her presence is just
so strong throughout and she influences
everything and is something that I
wanted to see in descriptor obviously
I've not not been able to yeah yeah well
that's great the hunt for the will of
people this this I didn't really
diverged much from that script cause it
was a very short shoot and we're really
cuz we're shooting outside and there's
limited debt was shooting in winter as
well so it was like short days and
really harsh conditions and so there
wasn't a lot of time to just improvise
or to kind of go off off script so stuck
to that script quite yeah quite strictly
can they be found online that's a good
question I don't know I don't know I
thought that they would be all online I
don't and I apologize if they're not I
am um I'd be really keen to know how you
because you have a brilliantly specific
vision and I'd love to know how you stay
true when you talked about the different
versions of world of people are really
dark one and the one you ended up with
how you trade stay true to your vision
when that scripts out to market because
I remember meeting Carthew pitching
world of people like three years before
you made it how do you hold on to it
we're in finance ears might be trying to
pull it in all sorts of different
directions I think we don't ask for much
money in New Zealand so yeah Tom Cruise
was playing the kid
I'm gonna give you your three million
dollars so do you deal with that
pressure then ratcheting up when you're
on Ragnarok well that was very different
because it's you know that was my I was
like just pull them to do that and that
was not my you know it wasn't my idea or
my yeah my IP or anything so that was
all my your voice though through it but
yeah how did you I was very lucky with
there because I was always be obviously
nervous about working with a studio in
general but they the I mean I did two
pictures with them and the pictures were
really like one of them was just to kind
of give a tonal idea of what I wanted to
do and now I made this little reel of
just basically ripping clips from lots
and lots of movies that looked exciting
and put an input immigrant song over the
top of it and that seemed to work and
then they didn't even in the picture and
then and then they basically brought the
song and you knowing that they wanted to
use it somehow in the film but the pit
but pitching I think as jet is really
just it's less about your idea and more
about sussing each other out and Kent
you in figuring out if you can bear to
work with each other for two years and I
found them really lovely people and so
it's so I ended up kind of just subtly
pushing my voice and tone and stuff into
the film from the beginning but they
wouldn't have hired me unless they had
seen those other films and had known
that somehow their time was gonna end up
in there I I suppose it's kind of
similar but I'm kind of at the start of
my career and I guess I was interested
in like structurally a lot of the
decision makers of white so when you're
trying to explore themes that are
culturally to do with your heritage and
largely the gays might you know have a
certain perception of how it should be
have you ever had to kind of deal with
managing kind of I suppose
know some feedback because I think it's
about trying to stay true and have
integrity and what you make for them
when people have got certain power kind
of instill their beliefs in a way that
you just don't agree with but they're
calling the shots to some degree I'm
really curious how you kind of navigate
that because I think I'm I'm yet to it
I've started to experience it in some
ways but I'm sure it's just the
beginning so one good trick is to just
put something in the script it's so you
know is going to trigger them and I was
going to distract them so much that
they've kind of like they don't notice
that you're you know you're things that
you really want to be in the script well
other times you just like save it till
the very last you know so sometimes what
I would do is know that I was going to
have a certain joke or a certain moment
or a certain scene and then wait until
it got financed and then put it in by
the day like yeah you got to be you got
it's all tactics in so and then you know
other times should be what you'd go and
then yeah and then Ricky's walking along
and there he falls down a through a
trapdoor and then because it slides down
through the earth in two like a
fantastical land for the dragons and
stuff for now I don't know about this
dragon thing but meanwhile got you on
either side of that your food and these
like the things that you really want on
the movie so yeah so there I think that
work sometimes but also it's alright I
think I'm the it gets easier the more
obviously the more that you do and you
know like they don't [ __ ] with me
anymore well was I film commissioned for
a long time and they were always pretty
respectful of my stuff I think just
because I didn't really know what I was
really trying to do and there were
see what happens and because of all my
films did well in New Zealand they you
know the more and more that that
happened they like kind of just like any
you can just do another film I guess but
but in the it but when I was starting
off I could have easily just taken all
the notes and just listened to them in
one thing but I love the way that we
finance films in New Zealand but one
thing one of the problems we've always
had in development is being that the the
development staff come in and they only
have a two year two or three-year tenure
so they it's about time you've done all
the noise and you've developed the
script tears then new people come in and
then they read the script in the going
off this and I go back to the first
draft and then until you start the
development so I know people who have
gone through development at the Film
Commission years ago like in the early
2000s who had been developing scripts
for eight years with them and just going
out of their minds because they you know
putting all of the eggs of the vet
basket and all right my development
process is I just develop stuff with
myself so I write my scripts without
asking for any finance for writing I
just do it for myself
and get it to the best place that I can
imagine the film being and then go and
say it's not gonna get any better than
this yes or no
instead of here's a rough first draft
what do you think well here's a synopsis
because then if you're going that
synopsis stage I think it's like there's
a pretty dangerous because then that
gives them all the opportunity of the
world to give you notes and to change
everything whereas if you spend two
years writing the script by yourself any
spare time whatever I did I was working
and writing then going with something
that's pretty solid dinner doesn't give
them much opportunity to to mess it up
better Saul so I yeah this is the real
world so I understand it's like you know
it's hard to work and also write
something and and spend all that time
you ever let anyone direct something
that you've written I've thought about
it and the I don't I don't think I'm I
don't think I'm emotionally stable
enough
I'm already suggestion hey how does you
work as a scriptwriter affect you when
you're working on something like Thor or
the Mandalorian where you know you're
coming in as a director higher but
obviously you know you write in your
right well so how does that affect it
was challenging for me on tour it was
challenging because again Jakob wanted
to control all of those elements and and
having a script come in that you know
was not in my style if it was a good
script it wasn't my style I found that
hard but I I always get to do his passes
on script so that was built into my
contract on Thor was I could get dude a
party like a story fast and dialogue
pass and stuff and change a little
things and so for instance black Korg
was that character I basically just good
they said oh what this rock character
maybe put them in for one thing and then
I did my pass on the scripts characters
and there's maybe quite a lot so yeah
it's about then but then something like
Mandalorian which really just directing
on there and in that section quite nice
for me just do it because if it's a good
script then I feel like I can
concentrate more on the directing
instead of freaking out every day and
like changing like writing on set and
going okay say this in I just can just
concentrate on what it looks like my cat
and I and I remember reading somewhere
that you were really inspired by Akira
when you were younger watching you is
there anything that you watched when you
run yeah anything else you watched when
you were younger or even more recently
that you felt really inspired by yeah
the film's inspired a lot of my stuff
you can see it cuz I've ripped them off
every every single movie at Badlands the
Graduate now and the end days of heaven
just only if the suns and the right
if anything recently that you wish you'd
read should riffin I really love death
of Stalin it was great
writing if it was written but you know I
love all her stuff and I think doctors
there they was just like but the
dialogues are smart and and then also I
thought get out was like brilliant and I
thought that just in terms of writing it
was I really just streamlined and
perfect right here sorry for the next
generation of New Zealand filmmakers
have you got any advice in general or do
you think that it needs to go on do you
think it needs to go and you need
direction or just any advice I think
it's gonna evolve into different like I
don't think my I'm not sure that there's
I don't think that kind of make films
like my films cuz its
there's only I think this in the eyes
you can only handle two and there's a
certain amount of the style you know
because I there yeah so I would say like
there's there are different like there
are different directions that New
Zealand film was going to hit and I
can't really predict where there is I
know everyone's trying make Horrors with
every moment and this like a big thing
so I don't mind I just I don't really
know how I would be able to make a
horror this wouldn't be scary and but I
think advice for for any young filmmaker
and even in New Zealanders just my thing
was like years it's basically the stick
to a vision please stick to your vision
and and I'm always very wary about
giving advice because I was told I was I
was dictated to a lot when I first
started by the older generation of
filmmakers and now I realize I shouldn't
have listened to them in the first birth
of my first short films and stuff you
know I got over the two kinds of a night
there's edits and that which I
instinctively knew I wanted
a certain thing and in the film that I
was convinced by both people who had
more experience not to do them and to do
things in a certain way and then only
like a year or two later like realize
like so and then I say that was a big
lesson for me and I started just
deciding to stick to what I
instinctively wanted and and and to
really just question because it's just
someone's opinion and it doesn't matter
what their experience is it's it's
you've got to sort of filter it really
you know take some experience if it
really makes sense I'll take some advice
that really makes sense but also listen
to yourself that you're not gonna that's
why I think my films fail it's because
of me not because you know I can't I'm
yeah I like having the excuse that if
something I do is a failure it's it's
it's all my fault instead of I could
just I don't want to have the excuse of
yeah but I should do that because you
know because it's not that's just being
weak and you know you're not sticking to
your guns do you think we're doing
something then like Thor and you know
having that kind of 180 million dollar
and then obviously you were probably
getting offered and doing things there
or maybe not of that scale but so it is
there can your voice could your voice
get lost
oh can definitely get lost but that's
also that you know I knew going to thaw
that my strength was not action movies
or superhero movies my strength was tone
and character and dialogue and moments
and so I just concentrated on that stuff
on my strengths knowing that this was
the 17th movie in a ram that had had you
know eight seventeen consecutive
box-office hits so I thought okay you
guys probably know what you're doing in
that department I'll just try and inject
the stone into the thing and but if I
had tried to like come in and reinvent
the genre or anything I would have been
you know fell on my ass pretty quick I
think
I you also see a fan of malok an
improvisation like you said you were
improvising lighting in the vampire
movie is that something you could
practice as a writer is to get behind
the camera and actually start making
shorts whether you've got a desire to
become a director and actually just to
get behind the camera and then make
shorts cuz I'll start doing that myself
just to kind of prove that it works on
screen as you get people read your
script this always doesn't work on
screen and do you think that's a good
practice just in general to get behind
the camera and get noticed that way and
yeah yeah I do I think it's important
for it to know all all the departments
even though I don't even only learnt
will check mccrane was you know but like
it's important to know as much as
possible all of the departments and how
everything works but also yeah to figure
out how because a lot of actors don't
understand what goes into making a
they're there for the moment they're
yeah but how do I look cool you know
that's their thing because they don't
really understand like if you want them
to say a certain thing we're student way
though it fits into this giant puzzle
there they're not aware of and so when
so for me coming from acting into
filmmaking and putting together a short
film I started realizing oh yes like
this is a massive like Rubik's Cube
where you just you know there's so many
things to think about and then also then
you know I've changed so much and in
terms of like the kind of stories I
wanted to tell I was very self centered
in the in the in the early day as well
since like ah just my vision and my you
know it's my story and if the audience
doesn't get it a little hair just dumb
like but you just can't think like that
like it's not I mean some people can and
get away with it but you have to
consider the audit like this but they
say basically first and I consider now
because what the audience experience is
gonna be and you know when is the
audience's bladder at bursting point you
know when are they sitting there though
[ __ ] doesn't need to go the toilet
I can't concentrate on the story anymore
but you have to think about that stuff
and like when are they bored when
they're like you must think just because
you know this thing happened to you in
your childhood that this is like
everyone else and
is gonna love it no one gives a [ __ ]
about your childhood like they just want
a good story so I sort of rethink the
way I was approaching story and just
realized yeah this good stories to be
told but also it's it's entertainment
and it's you know you have to actually
you're serving the audience so you know
they are paying $18 nowadays probably
you know for the right to come in and
observe and criticize your work and you
can't get upset with them for you know
if they don't like it you've got to work
your house to try and make something
that you know it's a gift to them and
that they are satisfied with it at the
end I basically all the questions I was
praying and asking you've already
answered them so I'm just gonna go to my
backup question which is I've noticed
that you kind of use the same actors
recurrently in all your films and is
that to do with the fact that you're
very inspired by obviously your homeland
New Zealand and you kind of want to
incorporate that but I just add in the
same New Zealand actors throughout your
films that you're making yeah and a lot
of it was just from my theatre days yes
working and co-ops and just yeah working
with your friends and then you develop a
shorthand where I love working with
actors who I know well because I can you
can just get past all the [ __ ] and
just say that was boring do it again you
know like you know instead of like you
know that was shitty do it again make it
better
and say it faster that's it and like
because then they'd so if when you get
past their people oh okay great yeah I
know and then I encouraged them to give
me [ __ ] as well like you know all sides
and often my friends were like that's
your direction there's your big
direction
and so it's writing with them in mind as
well a lot of them here yeah that's it
just makes my job easier and it's a lot
faster for me as well after work
instead of having to have conversations
about you know we do it does like you
know a hundred takes when they wanted
you know there's no difference um you
talked about your background as a visual
artist I was wondering how that informs
your screenwriting do you start with a
really visual idea or is it more
character and dialogue based and there's
the vision vision yes it's a mixed
definitely visual and it's been a lot of
time making a playlist
listening to a playlist when I write but
there that I definitely done it in all
my films had songs in mind that I've
written into the scripts and often I
can't afford them so much during the
heavens but yeah so I'll do that so it's
a mixture of that and then and then
visually like a lot of yeah that's like
images or photos or things that you know
that called to see some really good like
yeah eclipse like a lot of images and
just have the back big folders of things
I can just look at and sometimes they're
just really weird and don't really
inspiring other times they just might
just give you an idea of setting or
something you know but but the most
power try and watch watch films but I
try my old old films really to to give
me ideas I feel like I feel a bit too
close to contemporary cinema to be like
looking at things and then steered like
not said well you know
yes dealing you know I'd rather steal
from something really old it's harder
for people to find out
I'm on the similar sort of note I'm
interested in your writing process so
when you go from having the first Jo of
an idea for something to writing your
first draft do you do you spend a lot of
time sort of really digging into and
thinking you really really know your
characters inside out before you start
that first draft and do you outline and
do a treatment and know every scene or
do you just kind of crack on with your
first draft and then we write we write
we write yeah I do
the lots of notes and beats and I could
try and figure out the story before
typing because I found that typing is
really horrible and just it just hurts
your body and your mind to sit in front
of the blank screen now what's next I
like to just have the whole plan out in
front of me and know basically how I
rise I'll start with the beginning in
the end that's what I really like
visually or like just something like
things like this would be a cool way to
end a movie and there's a bit cool last
image for an audience to see this would
be a cool first image and this would be
a cool way to open the film and then
after then I'll put in some scenes
throughout I think this would be a great
thrill at the scene and then eventually
when I've got enough of these scenes or
sequences then lazily just glue them all
together with some sort of connecting
scenes but it's it really it's sort of
what I'm that's my style and when I know
what it is then I can write really fast
but if I'm just sitting there with nope
if you would say no story about you know
soothsayer on a mission to find some
some heads in a fantasy land and then I
just had to look at a blank page I would
not be there for a year without typing
anything and this I sat down and like
write it out and figured it all out for
you yell it out oh you've got the mic
I'm coming from Perry so just for you so
it's my turn to speak
I'm I'm I'm Wendy from Twitter I don't
know if you remember I sent you stuff so
everything sent to you but I just we
don't say that you are daily inspiration
and you I was the best role model I
could out for and my question is what
were your inspiration for Roger Rabbit
except the book Cajun skies I have a
letter for you so Jojo rabbit is just
for those of you don't know it's a film
the just shot and I'm editing at the
moment sitting World War two and it's
it's not a comedy it's a comedy drama
about a little boy in the Hitler Youth
who's trying to be the best man so you
can and you were in it and can you play
and that's a spoiler earlier they lose
[Laughter]
which I do rap so when did you start
writing what I started writing 2011 yeah
and then shot this year so I think
basically all my scripts have taken but
over six years
do you write then does that mean that
you're writing three or four on the go
alright I wrote that and then I wind
made work doing the shadows and rule the
people in four and then came back and
shot this this yeah but I actually
that's the way I prefer to write and
this is my little is my little trick
none of you will want to do I will write
a draft and I'll put her away for a year
or so and then within two years within
three years and you know I'll come back
to it and I'll read it okay who wrote
this [ __ ] and then I will read it like
maybe two or three times and then I will
throw that away and then rewrite it from
page one based on the memory of how I've
what I read and then my hundred and
twenty page script will suddenly be 80
pages and it will just be the bare bones
and just
like the the yeah the important parts or
the member of the things right remember
remember from reading the script and so
I think there's a there's a quite a good
filter system and then when you had like
this very sort of bare-bones short
version of your story then you can add
back in some tonal staphon's and you
know more jokes and [ __ ] yes so it takes
a long wait longer than anyone wants to
do any other scripts do you have in the
drawer how many queue oh wow that's just
I just put them in a rule drive
somewhere I don't wanna throw it away
but I make sure I don't look at it again
yeah hello I Drive all the way from
Siberia to ask you this question but no
a very serious one how many hours of
actual typing can you do in a day and do
you also call procrastination important
research I don't I don't call it
important research well you know who
knows I mean I end up so for instance I
uh
oh and then the character turns up and
as trans-am I must look at TransAm x'
and then I will spend three hours
looking at TransAm and then try and buy
one and because I think I need to own
one to know if the character should
drive one and then eventually I'll then
I was like what am i doing what these
you just drive a Toyota and then I'll
get back into things but so it's it's
useless for the script but it's good for
me to know more about transients
in case they ever need to talk about
ransoms and so so yeah so so I do I try
my hardest to turn the internet to
millions me off and when I'm writing but
in terms of hours of of typing I try and
spend the Hobby any I was typing I
really do a dive dive dig heads like
that like what you call it here this
parasite I get there a bit when I'm
tight like it's I just don't like it so
I just spin I tried like okay no I know
what I'm gonna write little bit a little
bit and then I'll stop maybe three hours
a day do you ever leave I don't know
what he left us do you ever stop halfway
through knowing what you're actually I
see you've got something to pick up on
the next day sometimes to do this thing
and the friend of mine came out this
really great system which is when he was
writing multiple things so sometimes
when writing multiple scripts which is
there's a good system so you break up
your work load into 20-minute breaks and
you set a time to 20 minutes and at the
end of that 20 minutes then you force
yourself to move on to the next group
and then after that 20 much you for self
to move on to the next project
so you do it with three things so every
hour you're doing working 20 minutes on
three projects then what's good about it
is you've only spent 40 minutes away
from the original project and so the end
of that 40 minutes you still remember
yet what ideas you left off it so you
smart like are really into finish this
idea of give himself another two minutes
if you just force yourself to stop you
won't forget we were in Uganda next
thing and I found that that's quite good
if here and the pressure that right lots
of stuff at the same time try it
hello and sorry apologies if oh yeah
apologies this is a bit done specific
but when you're acting on screen and
when you're directing at the same time
how do you manage that do you storyboard
it very precisely beforehand you watch
back every take or do sometimes say that
felt right let's use it and
hope there's no nasty surprises in the
Edit yeah that's the third one yeah yeah
at this with the diesels not enough time
for me to watch stuff back and also I
don't like watching any of that stuff as
very cringe it's cringy enough being in
your own movie I mean that's just tacky
then let's have the audacity to like
then watch yourself back in front of the
crew you know like watch it again they
were like no no it's embarrassing enough
don't like putting yourself in your
stuff so are you gonna keep doing it oh
yeah I mean I love myself I love I think
I was a very very good actor but yeah
it's art but I learned to really trust
all the people around me so especially
the DP in my first and having people
around who who had permission to say
that was terrible you know if I really
felt it like you know and I could I can
trust people to say that to me and not
feel bad about it because 80% of the
time it probably is bad because I'm not
thinking like you know like most actors
have the time to just actually think
it's solidly just about that thing and
whereas I that's why I make sure that my
characters aren't like the main
character or they're not they don't
carry the story dramatically so much
they're just like silly characters where
I can get away with that like Kevin
Costner
don't forget me checking my watch so I'm
here all the way from sunny Brighton and
which shows I think more dedication the
coming from France so my question to you
is you mentioned the importance of
shitty jobs and having just come from my
shitty job this morning I was wondering
which of those experiences his most
influenced your work and which has had
the most lasting impact on you I mean
not that you know it's probably unfair
to say they'd done they were all very
rewarding in some ways and you
definitely if any money was great but I
tell you that the hospitality was for me
like I think that's why so many actors
do it as well like it's you basically
performing all day for people and trying
out different characters a lot of times
you know you go different tables and try
different you know stupid voice so you
trying to entertain them or you'd be
grumpy and be pissed off and you just be
an [ __ ] to some tech tables and so
then you will be also like meeting
different characters at all this table -
it taught me a lot about observing
people and and listening to conversation
that's stealing
that's the other big thing I do steal
people's conversations if you don't know
them that's even better
very can't find out that you stole it
yeah that's why I over Yahoo I listen to
people and listen to arguments and cafes
and stuff and just observing body
language in restaurants is amazing like
you've all done that you'll start doing
your like look over at these tables like
this at a first date
I think breaking up what's going on and
you just observe the body language again
just they even hearing what they're
saying you can really tell a lot by just
how tense someone is or relaxed someone
is or you know so I think yeah so what I
do now probably the restaurant industry
was the best thing I think we may be out
of time I'm really sorry we didn't get
to see two cars one night well it's on
the internet it is it's on
with sound I would recommend watching as
it really does give kind of it's
brilliant but also it gives an
indication of where you go as a
filmmaker I think it is good yeah it's
my first film they're so good I haven't
watched it since 2005 probably and just
seeing a little bit there I couldn't I
mean I still can't watch it but I think
it's a good thing to see yeah just like
how somebody can begin and then how and
I guess yet where I'm at now thank you
guys so much for having me thank you
guys for having me it's been real
pleasure to come here and is it this
fine city and I hope there was some sort
of anything useful in this conversation
but I really appreciate you taking your
time to come out today thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]